اذا علي القرني ورينا برناوي رائده فضاء
من السعوديه يحلقان خلال ساعات ضمن المهام
العلميه اي اكس تو المتجهه الى وكاله
الفضاء الدوليه من قاعده
في فلوريدا وذلك بصحبه رائدى امريكيين علي
اللاجرني البالغ من العمر 31 عاما هو طيار
مقاتل برتبه نقيب يقود طائرات اف 15 ويملك
12 عاما من الخبره في هذا المجال اما ريان
برناوي تعمل
اختصاصيه ابحاث ومختبرات هي حاصله على
بقالوريوس علم الانجاب والهندسه الوراثيه
وتطوير الانسجه من جامعه اوتاكو في
نيوزيلندا برناوي تملك 9 سنوات خبره في
الماء مجال الخلايا الجذعيه السرطانيه كما
حصلت على ماجستير من جامعه الفيصل في مجال
العلوم الطبيه الحيويه من يقرر ان تدخل
التاريخ كاول امراه سعوديه وعربيه تنطلق
في رحله الى الفضاء اربعه عشره تجربه
بحثيه وعلميه يجريها رائده الفضاء
السعوديان علي القرني وريان برناوي ليسطرا
للمملكه عصرا جديدا في الفضاء ويلهما بلا
شك ملايين الاطفال في السعوديه والعالم
العربي من اجل استكشاف المزيد من اسراري
الكون لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات